oh when i was in a plane i have to hold
on in the islands
so that's why i have two i have like
drip and milk from here and here
and here so i have it like bend marks
from the plane
[Music]
how long were you homeless for start
super homeless 2011
was too hard because it was every single
day you have to
to realize where you're gonna sleep
where you're gonna eat
if somebody's homeless it's difficult
because it's by himself in the street
he can't do nothing it can be bullied in
the street it can be killed in the
street
it can happen something can happen to
him to him in the street no one is gonna
be watching
so that's how you say if someone is in
the street it's difficult because you
eat in the be
in the dustbin you sleep in a crash
your blanket get dirty you close that
dirty everything you dirty
so for me i thought like if i'm going to
end up like this i don't want to see my
dreams in my life end up like this
until i become an old man and after that
i die it's better to die
trying
yeah i used to call it magazines in
airports so i used to
get like magazines when we are sleeping
in a way we are sleeping formless in the
night i used to read these magazines
when i read that book everything just
come out from there i saw everything
from that book
from there i know it okay our
opportunity our opportunity
is only this to do it to fly out in this
country
we just organized the the the day of
that night
we say this day is going to be this just
day for us to live
and so when we start to leave we destroy
everything where we head in that camp
which is throw it like plunker to
destroy everything what we had
after that we said if we destroy this
we're not coming back
we're going there to do what we're going
to do to live so we just take our
chances and left
so you climbed inside the wheel of the
plane yeah
yeah you can't just like go in the same
time and just walk
straight away today to the plane you
can't do that because
they can see you and you can be arrested
as well
so definitely wait wait do we stand like
that
i know it's that it seems like it's my
target so i can be able to go
to do what i have to do so i can go the
street
and step to the wheels and climb over
until inside
that's how it is it was simple but was
dangerous but
for me and khalid was seems like was a
piece of a cake you know
so you're in the plane now yeah how did
you
secure yourself oh when i was in a plane
i have to hold on in the islands so
that's why
i have like drip and milk from here and
here and here
so i have it like bend marks from the
plane so i have to stick myself
hold the irons to make sure i'm not
falling out
but for my friend i don't know i call it
what he did
because you are sitting next to me to
the right side
so we have just been divided by the
wheel because the will when it comes in
you have to divide us by two quality is
going to be
outside me i'm going to be this side so
what was it what was it like when the
plane
took off i wanted planes
the fear was not there because me i was
feeling present you know i was feeling
present say yeah
carleton said to me yes we made it it
was only the
last words for him to say that you know
it was the last word for him to say that
when we say he made it i was like oh
yeah we made it here even me i was
excited because
the plane just left without any problem
in the floor like sweetheart to come
and stop the plane or maybe been spot
maybe
climbing over to the plane no nothing
did happen
when i mean there i can see some houses
i can see some cars down there
because when it goes up you have to go
like this so when it goes up it gives
you a big view
you can see you can see all the places
down there
i remember just there all the time
carleton where we made it
essentially is after it passed out with
oxygen
where did you fall when you fell out the
plane where did you land
i fall out in a landing gear the plane
was still like
floating to come down so when i come out
there means i come out with the speed
of the plane when i fail there is a part
like it can be like
10 or to 10 to 20 feet i remember when
they
cleaned it comes in heater it opens i
fell out when i fell out i hit the floor
when i hit the floor i start to wake up
but when i wake up i see two people who
are coming
they say hey check this guy jump out in
the plane i was like
maybe i'm just dreaming maybe i'm still
inside the enterprise i just have this
dream
no was not a dream was a real thing
because these two guys they just come
and pick me up i
i saw them when they picked me up and i
was like oh
this dj is happening because i fell out
in a plane i said i
doubt it did happen when they come to me
and they came
up they came up they took me to hospital
they tried to help me for
for my body to come back because they
were like putting some heaters i was i
was like frozen
like frozen my body was frozen because
my blood was not uh
circulating was not circulating so they
have to put like
heaters to to make me comfortable so my
body can heat up
it can heat up so my black in my blood
can start to work
i stayed there like about six months
como after that when i woke up
i can't move i can't do nothing i was
like stable i was like i can't do
nothing
i can't take the ball they have to pump
me in the bed i was like
oh my god yes i can see what's happening
to me you know
but i'm just led because i'm alive you
know they show me a passport for carlito
say you know you know this guy said i
know him they show my passport i say i
know him
saying never make it he never make it
but i'll say
how you say you fall on top of the
building so
i didn't know what did it happen to him
he met when he fell out
i was already passed out with the oxygen
i never seen nothing
i'm feeling guilty because me and him
were just came from africa
to come here to look for for for
surviving for
to make a better future i can say now
i'm very very
sad for him because he died in a long
way of the
long wave journey from johannesburg to
hydro
he never make it but i wish if he was
here today maybe something was going to
be different because
this was going to maybe it was going to
be a day
for our best day in our life
where are you what's going on today
where where are you in the uk
and what are you doing oh no i'm in
liverpool so far so far
uh my life is quite is not like perfect
i have to take what i can get but as
long as i can breathe
i can survive i can live i can eat
that's it that's what i'm expecting on
it
i did not get any help you know until
this
year until dc i met some uh like
like a few people that want to come to
help me some of them
they just show up and after that you
never see them and
see them anymore again so only i have
only one
guy now he's like trying to help me and
when my situation
how i live you know tell me who who is
this guy
gabriel
so it was i think it was just a it was a
cold day
and then i've just seen him outside
tesco and i just said to him are you
good bro
do you want anything from inside he told
me get me a coffee and i think he said
ham and cheese sandwich
so i went in there i got him the stuff
and i just gave it to him i just went
about my day i didn't think anything of
it
and then maybe two or three days later
my sister sent me the article
from the daily mail of timber and i was
looking at it
racking my brain for maybe a few days
thinking where do i know this guy where
have i seen his face before
it was driving me mad and then i kept
looking back through the article and i
basically
saw okay he's living in liverpool now so
i put two and two together and realized
he's a guy i saw
outside tesco two days earlier so i said
to all my friends
i said i'm gonna change this guy's life
i'm gonna find him
i was driving back home with my friend
and i saw him on the main road and i
said to him
oh that's him so i turned the car around
i pulled up on him honk the horn i told
him get him bro
we went to audi i bought him a bunch of
food
choices yeah just some any stuff that i
thought cool he will need this this will
help him live a better life and then
he took because obviously he can't carry
the bag so he got out the car i got the
bags we went into his house
and obviously or his house and obviously
when i saw the way he was living
i just thought no matter what amount of
food or clothes
i give this guy it's not going to change
his life
unfortunately so i told him cool stay
here bro i'm going to come back tomorrow
the next day i came back took him to
mine got him a haircut
some new clothes showered and then yeah
from then we've just been
trying to do what we can to make his
life better i guess
what's it how does it feel to have
that kind of support and friendship
here yeah for me that friendship for me
it look if he feels something like
his alive you know because i can feel it
in my heart so this guy
just make his own move movement without
like nothing stopping him you know just
to come and help me you know
do you guys have plans going forward how
else
do you think you can help him well for
me
the number one plan is to get him
somewhere permanent
a nice roof over his head where he can
wake up in the morning feel good
shower and start his day right obviously
he wants to do
college he wants to learn to speak
english he wants to do courses
and in his current situation now i know
i wouldn't be able to focus in
that environment so yeah the main aim is
to get him somewhere
where he can live and feel comfortable
and feel safe there are people out here
who
have had a bad set of cards dealt to
them and
they do deserve a blessing so yeah when
you see someone on the street or when
you see someone don't always neglect
them
take some time to actually find out who
they are and you never know maybe you'll
be able to change their life too
i want the god to look after after this
guy as well because this guy is decent
and he's please he do it for me to his
heart you know
he drew it from his heart you can see
guys like this one they need to be
trusted
from the eyes of their god because they
are do it with with their heart they
don't do it with a
doji you know they don't play dodgy
thing yeah
and then literally my
break right and i i slammed my throttle
fully forward really quickly i just
rolled to 120 degrees
i pulled really really hard towards the
ground he immediately
started pumping out flares and they act
as a decoy to the surface-to-air missile
that had just launched and it had
locked onto my engines